evanston illinois north of chicago
was one of the most segregated cities in
america
when black americans escaped slavery in
the south
discrimination and depression followed
them here
black residents were only allowed to buy
property in this
one small area of the city and that only
ended around 50 years ago
the area was deprived of investment
parks
playgrounds stores even today
it has no public school and children a
bust around the city
this was widespread in america but
evanston
is the first city to offer financial
compensation
known as reparations pursued by robin
rose simmons
it's not going to put a dent in the
damages that have been done to black
evanston residents
but we understand that steps are
necessary it'll certainly take lifetimes
it'll take generations it took us 402
years
to get to this place in history to get
to this place of our
our racial divide based on
egregious crimes against the humanity of
black people
sarah is one of those residents eligible
for an initial
25 thousand dollars of reparations
people
didn't even see blacks
as you know the same
so now that there's a recognition that
harm was done and that evanson is the
first place
in the united states to say hey you know
we're taking some ownership of this
i think it's a great um
i just i like being part of this history
you only need to travel one block
outside of this neighborhood to see how
far black residents have been left
behind
and the wealth gap is growing
even now the vast majority of mortgages
in evanston are going to white people
the reparations are well intended but
the money has to be spent on housing
and it has to be spent here in evanston
the reality is
many black residents simply can't afford
to buy here anymore
jennifer is one of those people it's not
just a money thing because it's not
you know i shouldn't have to worry
just because of the color of my skin
whether i'm going to be
treated fairly for some local policies
simply help
far too few people and give the federal
government an
out in offering adequate compensation
to the descendants of slavery we know
america can do it on the federal level
we just saw about 10 trillion dollars be
printed for covet relief it didn't
affect any budgets
there's no inflation they just printed
the money
so we want to see that on a federal
level for
every american descendant of slavery not
just those
in one particular municipality the
compensation may be imperfect
and long overdue but it started a
national conversation
about how to repair racism every great
journey starts with the first step
i think people should embrace it yes
there's going to be flaws like anything
else
but if we never get started then what a
small step
but is in the right direction sally
lockwood sky news
evanston illinois